(logo whooshing)
- [Narrator] This
program is a presentation
of University of California Television.
Your support makes UCTV's
programming possible.
Contribute online
at uctv.tv/support.
Check out or YouTube Original channel,
UCTV Prime,
at youtube.com/uctvprime.
Subscribe today to get
new programs every week.
(serene music)
(audience applauding)
- Well, thank you very much.
I should remind you that
my brother is a novelist,
and so a writer of fiction.
(audience chuckling)
I felt very honored
and also very flattered
to be invited to give this
Howison Lecture in Berkeley
in 2012.
And the feeling was only increased
when I read the list
of my predecessors in this office,
some 70-odd lecturers,
some of them really pretty odd,
but on the whole,
a very, very distinguished lot.
You have no hope of hearing anything
of the same standard
as what you would have heard here
20 or 30 years ago.
I feel also that what I have to say
would not have commended itself
to the philosopher for
whom this lecture is named.
But I do think that the subject
would have appealed to him
as a suitably philosophical subject.
The subject is death.
And death, after all,
is the final end of all our interests
and one of the few things in life
of which we can be really certain.
And I find each year
it becomes more certain.
(audience chuckling)
All the ancient philosophers,
the Epicureans
were particularly preoccupied by death.
They thought,
they said,
that most men
live in terror of dying,
perpetually wracked, as Lucretius put it,
by the fear of Acheron,
which shakes human life
from top to bottom,
which covers everything
with the black of night,
which prevents all clear
and unsullied pleasure.
The reaper with the scythe
stands always at our shoulder,
his fleshless hand
directs our every thought and action,
and his inescapable presence
fills our every moment
with fear and trembling.
We are thanatophobes.
Poor, miserable thanatophobes.
Moved by that distressful
state of affairs,
the Epicureans,
being philanthropical philosophers
thought they could do something about it.
They offered their fellow men a cure
for their morbid disease.
This cure was not pharmacological,
it didn't involve taking
drugs or making drugs,
it was consequently very cheap
and had no side effects.
The cure was an argument,
a philosophical argument.
Take this argument, they said,
and your dread of death
will at first abate
and then disappear,
its place being taken
by pleasure, joy, and delight.
The argument ran roughly like this.
What happens, said the Epicureans,
to animals
when they die,
to animals, whether
they're ants or armadillos,
mice or men,
is that their souls
part company with their bodies.
Every animal, they said,
is a composite being,
composed of two primary bits:
a body and a soul.
So the death of an animal
is the dissolution of a composite being
and consequently, the
annihilation of that being.
Once dead,
a mouse exists no more.
And the same is true of men.
Now once it's dead in that case,
nothing more can happen to a mouse
or to a man
because there's nothing there
for anything to happen to.
And in particular,
nothing nasty
or unpleasant can happen
to a mouse or to a man
once it's dead.
For that being so,
there's no reason in the world
why anyone, mouse or man,
should give a hoot about being dead.
And in particular,
no reason in the world
why anyone should be afraid of being dead.
Death, as Lucretius says,
is nothing to us.
It's none of our business.
When he says that death is nothing to us,
he means being dead,
the state of being dead is nothing to us.
Dying, of course, the process of dying,
may be and sometimes was
a peculiarly unpleasant business.
He's not talking about that.
When he says death is nothing to us,
he means that my death is nothing to me
and your death is nothing to you.
It might well be
that your death meant a lot to me,
and also, though less probably,
that mine meant something to you.
He says nothing about that.
And when he says, Lucretius,
that death is none of our business,
what he means
is that whatever may happen once I'm dead
is no concern of mine.
It would be as absurd as irrational
for me to worry about being dead,
about what happens once I'm dead,
as it would be for me to lose sleep
over the question
of what happens on other galaxies,
or to waste my time
reflecting upon the political constitution
of Uruguay.
Lucretius himself doesn't, of course,
refer to Uruguay.
(audience laughing)
Whatever may happen
during a long period of time
in which I am dead,
none of that is any business of mine.
For, as the Epicureans like to put it,
when death is, I am not,
and when I am, death is not.
You might ask various questions
about that argument.
How good is it?
You might wonder, for example,
whether it really did the work
that the Epicureans thought it could do.
Suppose that I take in that argument
and think about it,
will I be cured
of this morbid fear of death?
Well, I don't know what
the answer to that is
beyond saying that it seems to me
that the Epicurean argument
was, therapeutically speaking,
at least as good as any cure
which any ancient doctor
offered for any ordinary disease.
(audience chuckling)
But my concern, qua philosopher,
so to speak,
is not with the question of
the ethicacy of the argument,
but whether philosophically speaking,
it's a decent argument.
That is to say
does it reach a true conclusion
by valid argumentation
from true premises?
And that's what I'm
going to talk about now.
It's perhaps worth,
at the cost of pedantry,
which is another name
I sometimes sing for philosophy,
(audience chuckling)
to set out the argument
a little more formally.
There are different ways of doing it.
Here's one way.
It has four premises, okay?
The first premise says
the death of an animal
is a separation
of its body and its soul.
A cat dies
when its body and its soul comes apart.
It's dead when its soul
and its body are apart.
That's the first premise, right,
what death is.
The second premise
says that animals are
essentially composites
of two bits, a body and a soul.
A cat
isn't a body which just happens
to be attached to a soul
nor a soul which just
happens to be in contact
with a body.
A cat is essentially a bipartite creature,
a soul plus body.
From those two premises
that death is separation of body and soul,
and that an animal is a composite
of body and soul,
it follows in the Epicurean argument
that once an animal is dead,
it doesn't exist.
Once my cat has killed the mouse,
the mouse exists no more
because the mouse is a composite
of body and soul,
and that composite exists no more,
having been separated by my cat.
The third premise claims
that nothing can happen to an animal,
or indeed to anything else,
at a time when it doesn't exist.
If that's so,
it follows
that nothing can happen to a cat
or to any other animal
at a time when it's dead,
because when it's dead, it doesn't exist,
and when it doesn't exist,
nothing can happen to it.
The fourth premise states
that if nothing can happen to an animal
at a given time,
then nothing which happens at that time
is of any concern to the animal.
If the cat isn't there
in 2014,
then nothing that happens in 2014
can be any business of the cat's.
And from that premise and
the preceding conclusion,
it follows that nothing whatever
which happens at a time
when an animal is dead
is of any concern to that animal.
Death is nothing to us.
When I was a boy
many years ago,
centuries ago,
when I first read that item,
I thought it was really bloody good.
I still think it's pretty bloody good,
but not as good as I thought it was.
You might first ask,
well, I don't know if you would,
I'm first going to ask,
well, what the Epicureans'
ancient colleagues
would have or did think of this argument.
First of all,
though they disagreed with the Epicureans
on almost every point in philosophy,
all ancient philosophers
agreed with them on their first premise,
namely that the death of an animal
is the separation of
its soul from its body.
The first Christian philosopher
who wrote about the soul,
namely Tertullian, says
all the pagan philosophers agree
that death is the separation
of soul from body.
And he says they're right.
Of course
the pagans thought that death
was a natural event,
whereas Tertullian knows
that it's not natural,
but rather a punishment
visited on humans
because a certain woman
a long time ago
ate a fruit from a forbidden tree.
(audience chuckling)
But that diverting fantasy apart,
the Christian philosophers
agreed with the pagan philosophers
about the nature of death.
Death for all animals,
human or not,
is a decomposition,
a coming apart of body and soul.
So far, so good for the Epicureans,
but after that,
things go depart.
When you get to the second premise,
the premise according to which animals
are essentially composites
of body and soul,
you find that
Platonist philosophers disagree.
Take Arthur.
Arthur is a cat,
one of my cats,
one of my favorite cats
who's been dead for some time.
Nice gray cat.
Arthur, according to the Platonists,
was, when he was alive,
an embodied soul.
But Arthur was not a composite being.
He was not made up
of a feline body
and a feline soul.
No, he was a soul.
Well, he still is a soul, of course.
And he wasn't a feline soul, Arthur,
because souls don't come in species.
Arthur, rather,
was a soul who, for a while,
inhabited or took on a feline body.
In this life, he had a feline body.
When he died,
he took off his feline body.
So his death,
though it's a separation
of body from soul,
isn't a matter of extinction
or his ceasing to exist.
After all, Gypsy Rose Lee
didn't cease to exist
each time she reached the
climax of her striptease,
nor did she cease to exist
when she finally stripped off her body.
What happened to her after her death?
Well, who knows?
According to Plato,
I guess she probably returned to earth
in a new body,
perhaps the body of a peacock
or a hoopoe.
(audience chuckling)
Arthur, on the other hand,
being a virtuous cat,
was probably
(audience member laughing)
allowed by the infernal judges
to continue as a disembodied soul,
in which state, he now
enjoys, I like to think,
the pure and true pleasures
of philosophical contemplation.
(audience laughing)
However that may be,
according to the Platonists,
death isn't our extinction,
but we have every reason to worry about
what's going to happen to us
once we are dead.
Most ancient thinkers,
not unreasonably,
thought that from that point of view,
as from most others,
Platonism was absurd.
And of course, I agree with these people.
(audience member laughing)
The Stoics, for example,
and the Christians too,
agreed with the Epicureans
that we are composite entities.
Animals aren't souls.
They're bipartite things
consisting of bodies and souls.
Not only that,
Stoics and Christians would happily accept
the second premise of
the Epicurean argument,
that
when a cat or any animal is dead,
it exists no more.
But they thought,
or at least they would have thought,
had they addressed specifically
the Epicurean argument,
that this second premise
was not good enough
for the Epicureans.
For from the second premise,
that when an animal is dead,
it doesn't exist,
the Epicureans move on
to a conclusion that
after an animal's dead,
nothing can happen to it.
And this influence,
Stoics and Christians
would have pointed out,
doesn't work.
True.
While or when an animal is dead,
they might have said
nothing can happen to it.
It doesn't exist,
But it doesn't follow from the fact
that when it's dead,
nothing can happen to it,
that once it's dead,
nothing can ever happen to it.
When my cat, Galen,
I like to change cats
from time to time, died,
his body and soul parted company
according to Stoics and Christians,
and he ceased to exist.
Throughout the time in which he was dead,
he didn't exist.
And so, let us concede
nothing could happen to him.
But what
if he didn't stay dead?
What if the two parts of Galen,
like Richard Burton and Elizabeth Taylor,
divorced only to remarry?
(audience member laughing)
Well, that's not just a fantasy,
well of course, it's a fantasy,
but it's not just an invention.
It's exactly what does happen
according to the Stoics.
When we die,
our bodies and our souls part.
Eventually, the whole
world goes up in flames.
But then things start up again.
And with the inevitability of causation,
bodies and souls come back,
and there we are again.
The same old bloody thing,
one after another.
The Christian philosophers, of course,
held the same curious view,
or a similar view.
To be sure,
when I'm dead,
I don't exist.
There's one bit of me,
namely my body,
which is sleeping in a crematorium
and another bit of me,
namely my soul,
which is waiting in hell.
(audience chuckling)
It is waiting in hell.
But sometime later,
those two things are
gonna come together again.
What will happen then,
according to the Christians,
isn't quite the same
as what will happen
then according to Plato.
Rather,
what will happen then is either
that I shall have suffer
perpetual torment in hell
or else perpetual tedium in heaven.
(audience laughing)
In either event,
Christians had every reason to
be apprehensive about death,
not about what was going to happen
when they were dead,
but about what was gonna happen
when they stopped being dead,
(audience laughing)
when the last trumpet sounded,
and when the dead are raised.
Well, there are two, I think,
rather serious objections prima facie
to the Epicurean argument.
The Epicureans suppose
that we are essentially composite beings
of body and soul.
The Platonists say not at all.
The Epicureans suppose,
though they don't say this explicitly,
that once we're dead,
we're dead forever.
Other philosophers hold
that that's not true at all.
Sure, we're dead for a while,
but after a long while,
we revive.
There are numerous ways
in which an Epicurean might reply
to those objections.
I shan't mention the
replies which they gave
explicitly or implicitly,
but rather suggest the reply
that they ought to have given,
or at least the reply
that I'm going to give
on their behalf.
It's not an Epicurean
reply, but it's a reply
which does the best for the Epicureans
that can be done.
It means stepping back
to look again
at the first premise of the argument,
the premise that death
is a matter of the separation
of a body and a soul.
That notion, as Tertullian says,
was a commonplace in antiquity,
at least a commonplace
among ancient philosophers.
But it's not an evident truth.
I mean, it certainly isn't so to speak
what they call an analytical truth.
There's no part of the meaning of the word
to die in English
or of (speaking in
foreign language) in Greek
that dying is a matter of a soul
separating from a body.
And the more one thinks about it,
least the more I think about it,
the stranger it becomes.
A couple of days ago,
Perdita, the third of my
cats to be introduced,
(audience chuckling)
was sitting on the sundial in the garden.
She noticed a mouse.
There are lots of mice in the garden.
She jumped down,
caught the mouse,
played with it for a bit
as cats do,
whopped it with her paw and killed it,
and then ate it.
- [Audience Member] Oh!
- What happened?
Well, according to the
view accepted by all ancient philosophers,
what Perdita did
was skillfully separate
the mouse into two parts.
(audience laughing)
A mouse soul and a mouse body.
And she then ate the more nutritious
of the two parts,
(audience laughing)
minus the gallbladder.
Is that the plain truth of the matter,
that she divided the mouse into two parts?
I don't think anyone
would ever say that's so,
unless you were in the grips
of a curious philosophy
or very concerned to
make his audience laugh.
I mean,
okay, death is a matter of
separating body and soul.
You think of that in
your philosophical study,
but once you go out into the real world,
it doesn't seem the sort of thing
you're likely to say.
And it's worse than that.
It's worse than that
because when the ancient philosophers
say that death is a
separation of body and soul,
you might wonder what on earth they mean.
And in particular,
you might wonder what on earth they mean
by the word soul.
After all, we've all come across bodies
with a bit of luck,
(audience chuckling)
but I've never come across a soul,
partly because I've no
idea what it would be
to come across a soul,
and nor have you.
In order for the
Epicurean argument to work
and for this first premise,
that death is a separation
of body and soul
to be true or to have any sense,
I see I should refer to squirrels,
not to mice, alright?
We have to be able to give
some appropriate sense
to the word soul.
Not any old sense,
but a sense such that first,
that there will turn out
to be such things as souls,
and that secondly,
souls will be the sort of things
that could intelligibly be said
to be attached to and then
separated from bodies.
This, of course, is a complicated matter.
So I should be
as simple as possible.
It seems to me
that the only way to
make an honest expression
out of the term soul
is a roughly Aristotelian way.
The Aristotelian way, as I call it,
goes like this.
The something which differentiates
living things from nonliving things,
which differentiates cats from crystals
or comets,
that's the fact,
and this is trivial, okay?
That living things are,
as we say, animate.
The Greek word for animate
is (speaking in foreign language).
So living things are (speaking
in foreign language),
whereas nonliving things are
(speaking in foreign language).
And that's trivial, right?
The English word animate,
in a sense which is trivial,
that living things are animate
comes from the Latin animatus,
which is connected with
a noun anima in Latin.
And in the same way the Greek adjective,
(speaking in foreign language)
comes from the Greek noun,
(speaking in foreign language) okay?
Now the normal English
for the Latin word anima
is soul.
So animatus
might be translated as
something like ensouled or having a soul.
The normal English for the Greek word
(speaking in foreign language)
again is soul.
So the word (speaking in foreign language)
might be translated, and often is,
as ensouled or having a soul.
Now it's true.
It's a trivial truth
that living things are
(speaking in foreign language).
So it's true a trivial truth
that living things (speaking
in foreign language).
That's to say it's true,
a trivial truth,
that all living things have souls.
That's the way to present the word soul
and make sense of it.
You might think that in that case,
it's clear
that living things are
compounds of body and soul.
Perdita is a living thing,
so trivially, she has a soul.
She's animate, she's (speaking
in foreign language),
she has a soul.
Surely, she's evident
she also has a body.
And so it follows, doesn't it,
as the second premise has it,
that she's a compound of body and soul,
and that the dissolution of the compound
is her death.
Well, no, that's not true at all.
It isn't evident
that Perdita has a body.
Indeed, it seems to be quite evident
that my cat Perdita
doesn't have a body.
She is a body.
She doesn't possess a body
in the way someone might possess a hat.
She is a body.
Her body isn't a part of her.
It's her.
So,
can you see the cat, Perdita?
Yes.
Well, you can see a part of her.
Which part?
Her body.
That's absurd.
You see the body, you see the cat,
you see Perdita.
So forget about that, okay?
Imagine that's false.
Okay, as I say, she really has got a body.
She isn't a body, she has a body.
So suppose then
that Perdita has a body
and also, trivially, has a soul.
Doesn't it follow
that her soul is a part of her?
Well, not at all.
For her to have a soul
is for to be animate,
to be a living thing.
And for her to be a living thing,
as Aristotle says,
is for her to have a
certain set of capacities:
the capacity to nourish herself,
to reproduce,
which I'm afraid she no longer has.
We just had her spayed.
The capacity to eat,
to purr,
to move about,
to play, and so on.
To possess a soul,
to be animate is to possess a soul.
To possess a soul is to
have a set of capacities.
So what a soul is,
if it's anything at all,
is a set of capacities.
And a thing's capacities
are not a part of it.
In Herbert Reed's poem,
the Naming of Parts,
among of the parts you name,
the lower sling swivel,
the upper sling swivel,
and the piling swivel.
Haven't the faintest idea what they are,
but those are the parts of the rifle.
You don't also name
the capacity to kill a man at 500 yards.
That capacity, which is
possessed by the rifle,
isn't a part of the rifle.
If I change animals now for a moment,
a llama,
this particular llama is called Lorenzo,
has an apparently limitless capacity
to digest grass.
That capacity isn't a part of him
in the way in which his third stomach
is a part of him.
He also has a very keen sense of hearing,
but his keen sense of
hearing isn't a part of him
in the way his ears are parts of him.
In short, an animal's soul
being a set of capacities
isn't a part of an animal,
and an animal is a composite of two parts:
body and soul.
I think that that's the only sensible way
of dealing with souls and the like.
And I offer it to a good Epicurean.
I think that on that account,
the Epicureans will be able to get round
some of the more obvious objections
raised by Platonists,
Stoics, and Christians
to their argument about death.
Of course,
if they accept the Epicurean view,
if the Epicureans accept
the Aristotelian view,
they do so at a cost.
If you take the Aristotelian view,
death
may be the dissolution of body and soul.
When you die, you lose
your vital capacities,
but it doesn't follow
and it's not true
that when you die, you cease to exist.
And it's crucial to the Epicurean argument
that death is an extinction.
I actually think that's false.
Death isn't an extinction.
When my cat, Galen, died,
my granddaughter, Mary,
wanted to see Galen
before I buried him.
I showed her Galen in a cardboard box.
(audience member chuckling)
There was the cat, Galen.
He was dead,
but he hadn't ceased to exist.
After all, you could still see him,
touch him, and shed tears over him.
And he was, of course, still a cat.
A dead cat,
but nonetheless, a cat.
Generally speaking,
when things die,
they go on existing for a while.
Not often for very long,
but in a few cases,
for example, the case of Jeremy Bentham,
whom you can still see
in London for centuries.
Insofar as the Epicurean argument
requires that death be an extinction,
an end of existence,
the Epicureans must be cheery
about accepting an Aristotelian view
of the nature of the soul.
Nonetheless,
I think that
with various
modifications to their view,
they can reasonably hold,
or a Neo-Epicurean can reasonably hold
death, that Aristotle says,
is the loss of vital capacities
at death or shortly after
an animal ceases irrevocably to exist.
However that may be,
I want now to turn to the
third premise of the argument,
the premise according to which
when a thing doesn't exist,
nothing can touch it.
I find this premise, in some ways,
the most perplexing
premise of the argument.
In a way, it seems evidently true.
If the thing isn't there,
how can anything possibly happen to it?
On the other hand,
it's quite difficult to find
a precise formulation of the premise
which renders it true.
You might think the obvious way
of taking the premises,
something like this.
If an item doesn't exist at a given time,
then nothing whatever can
come to be true of the item
at that time.
Not that nothing can be true
of the item at that time.
Any number of things,
as Aristotle almost said,
are now true of Homer.
For example, that Homer's a poet,
that he wrote in Greek.
The fact that he doesn't exist
doesn't stop those
things being true of him.
But perhaps nothing can
come to be true of Homer
now that he doesn't exist anymore.
Well, you think about that for a moment.
It quitely is not true.
Any number of things every day
can't be true of Homer
which weren't true before.
Take the predicate,
schema has been read by N people, 'kay?
Has been read by 30,000 people,
30,001 people.
I take it that pretty well
every day of the year,
a predicate of that sort
comes to be true of Homer
which wasn't true of him before.
He gains new readers every year,
long after his extinction.
In the same sort of way,
world record holders
may lose their titles
long after they have ceased to exist.
Recently, a horse
has become tremendously famous
decades after its death.
And even philosophers
have their posthumous ups and downs.
(audience chuckling)
Nonexistence doesn't stop
things happening to you.
I mean, clearly, that's true, right?
There are any number of things
you might say about that.
I think the best way to approach it
is to take the third and the
fourth premise in tandem,
third and fourth premises
in tandem together.
The third premise says
if a thing doesn't exist,
nothing can happen to it.
Well, that's not true.
So we need something like
if a thing doesn't exist,
nothing of a given sort,
nothing of sort X can happen to it.
And then the fourth premise
reads something like
if nothing of a sort X
can happen to an object,
then it has no reason
to care about it, okay?
So we look for the magic ingredient, X.
Third premise now says
once a thing no longer exists,
nothing of a given sort
can happen to it.
And the fourth premise says that
if nothing of a given sort,
of that given sort can
happen to something,
then that thing has reason
for concern about it.
So what possible values are there
for this predicate,
this term, X?
All the ancient texts suggest
what one would think anyway,
that X has something to do
with helping and harming.
So you might think that the third premise
should be something like
if an object doesn't
exist at a given time,
then nothing which happens at that time
can help or harm it.
Well, that of course,
is quite clearly false.
Any number of things happened
before I existed
which harmed me.
For example, I now have frightful teeth
because before I ever existed,
my mother didn't get enough calcium.
But perhaps what really counts here
is that once a thing has ceased to exist,
nothing that happens thereafter
can harm it or hurt it.
Is that true?
Well, I don't know.
If you've been to Venice,
you would have seen in the
grand hall of the doges
that frieze of portraits
of the successive doges.
The portraits, every so often,
they're interrupted by black rectangles.
Those black rectangles
cover, blank out the portraits
of doges who suffered damnatio memoriae.
They were damned.
Their memory was damned.
Damnatio memoriae
is something that only happened to you
once you're dead.
You can't suffer damnatio memoriae
when you're still alive.
But surely, damnatio memoriae
is a frightful thing to happen to you.
It harms you.
It hurts you.
If I were a doge,
looking up at this
series of friezes of black spaces,
I'd think, good God,
I hope they don't give me a black part.
If they do,
that would be awful.
Well,
were the doges harmed posthumously
by having their memories
damned or weren't they?
I think that that's a
question for decision.
There's no true answer.
You just decide.
But I think that behind that
lies something like the following question
and following idea,
that even if the doge is harmed,
but he no longer exists,
he doesn't suffer from the harm,
he doesn't feel the harm, 'kay?
And surely, the Epicureans
really are getting in their third premise
at something of this sort.
Once an animal no longer exists,
it can't any longer feel or experience
anything at all.
(speaking in foreign language)
It can't feel or experience
anything pleasant or unpleasant.
anything agreeable or disagreeable.
At any rate, that seems to me
to be the most plausible way
of reconstruing the third
premise of the argument.
'Kay,
the sort X,
which can't effect us,
is a sort of felt suffering
or felt benefit.
If that's right,
then the fourth premise of the argument
must say
that if
at a given time,
I cannot feel or experience
anything pleasant or unpleasant,
then what happens at that time
is no concern of mine.
If from the given time onward,
an animal can experience nothing at all
and make with no sensation whatsoever,
then nothing which happens at that time,
according to the Epicureans
is of any concern to the animal.
I think something like that
was the fourth premise of
the Epicurean argument,
and I think that's ultimately
why the Epicurean argument doesn't work.
Because it's straightforwardly
false, I think,
that we have no reason to be concerned
about states of affairs
in which we ourselves
can have no feelings of any sort.
Okay.
Here are a couple of types of examples.
There are lots.
The first type of example
concerns what I call
altruistic fears and hopes.
Despite what the Epicureans
sometimes seem to say,
animals in general
and humans in particular
are just occasionally concerned
with things other than themselves.
Lorenzo the llama
cares for Leonora, his lady wife,
and for Laura, their daughter.
That's evident.
Female cats generally
care for their kittens.
And some human parents
actually care for their children.
In particular, one
animal may be frightened
for another.
I recently came across the case
of Lieutenant Colonel Pothecary,
it's a surname,
but it's a true story,
who commanded the British battalion
during the Second World War.
His battalion landed in Normandy on D-Day,
and just before D-Day,
Pothecary learnt that his eldest son,
who was a captain in the Royal Navy,
had had his ship torpedoed
and was drifting in Mid-Atlantic
in a small boat.
Pothecary was riven with fear,
fear for himself, of course,
since he was likely to meet pain,
mutilation, or death,
but also fear for his men,
who were likely to meet the same fate,
and for whom he was responsible,
and above all, according to this story,
fear for his son, whom he loved.
These you might call altruistic fears.
And as far as I can see,
they're just as oppressive
and just as real
as any egocentric fears.
And they're also just as rational.
That being so,
it follows, it's clear
that an animal and man
might be reasonably, in
certain circumstances,
fear his own death.
If a parent dies,
who's going to look after the children?
If Pothecary is killed,
what will happen to his men?
One of my heroes from English history
is Lord Nelson, Horatio Nelson,
frightful cad in many ways, but still.
He knew no fear.
He was also an ostentatious sort of chap.
At the Battle of Trafalgar,
he stood on the poop deck of HMS Victory
in his full naval finery.
And he was shot by a French sniper
and died shortly afterwards.
He hadn't been afraid to die,
but he ought to have been.
He also feared not for
himself, but for his men,
and also, of course, for England,
which expected that every
man would do his duty,
which Nelson clearly didn't do.
Had Nelson been properly afraid
and acted in accordance
with his proper fear,
fear not for himself,
but for other people and other things,
he would have survived
to encourage his men
and defend his country.
All that is perfectly obvious,
and you might say the Epicureans
must have thought of it.
Well, they didn't.
But apart from altruistic fears,
there are also egocentric reasons
for fearing death,
or at least for being
pretty reluctant to die.
I shan't
comment upon
that sort of angst or
existential fear of nothing,
which my brother so memorably describes
in his book.
I'm thinking of something much more banal
and much more common and real.
It's just this.
Most of us, most of the time,
have various long-term projects.
At the moment,
I'm trying to write a book
about the church fathers.
All of us, I suppose, most of the time
have middle-term projects.
For example, a project
to breed white canaries.
And we all, surely,
always have short-term projects,
even if it's only the project
to eat crackers in bed.
(audience chuckling)
If you have plans and projects,
then of course, you want
those plans and projects
to be brought to completion.
And normally, though not always,
the only person that can
bring them to completion
is yourself.
After all, some projects
can't be completed
by anyone other than yourself.
My project of writing a book
on the church fathers
could be completed after my death
by Tony Long, for example.
But my short-term project
of rereading Maupassant's Bel Ami
couldn't possible be completed
by anyone other than me.
Now if I'm writing a book,
I probably need to stay alive
for another two or three years to do it.
And that gives me a
reason for avoiding death,
(audience member laughing)
just as it gives me a reason
for trying to stave off Alzheimer's,
DTs, and all the other things
which senility brings on.
(audience member chuckling)
If it's my project,
this is terribly serious,
if it's my project to reread Bel Ami,
I need at least two or three hours.
And just as that gives me a good reason
for not wanting to fall asleep at once,
it gives me a good reason
for not wanting to die at once.
It doesn't, of course,
give me a reason
for being corroded with fear
at the thought of being dead,
but it does give me a reason
for being miffed
or vexed
or even enraged
if I learnt that I was about to die.
There's a further step, 'kay?
Each of us always has some project or plan
which can't be completed once we're dead.
Each of us therefore
always has a good reason
for not wanting to be dead,
indeed for wanting not to be dead.
Not that we have a reason
for wanting never to be dead,
nor that we ever have
a reason, or I don't,
for wanting to live for another 500 years.
But now, I have a reason
for wanting to live for
another five minutes,
say, to get to the end of this lecture.
(audience laughing)
And after five minutes,
I should have a reason
for wanting to live another five minutes,
to get over to the questions, and so on.
I'll always have a good reason
for not wanting to be dead
ad infinitum,
or rather, ad mortem.
For those reasons then,
I think that ultimately,
the Epicurean argument
doesn't reach its conclusion,
much so as mar the argument.
Hamlet says, "To die, to sleep,
"to sleep perchance to dream.
"Ay, there's the rub.
"For in that sleep of death,
"what dreams may come?"
There, the Epicureans
disagree with Hamlet.
They tell him, truly,
that death is not a sleep at all.
The big sleep isn't a big sleep.
Cemeteries, despite their etymology,
are dormitories.
Once you're dead,
you dream no more.
Hamlet goes on to ask,
"Who would fardels bear
"but for the fear of
something after death?"
And there, unless I'm mistaken,
the Epicureans agree with Hamlet.
They'd say, "True."
No one would bear fardels,
put up with this life
unless they're afraid that
things would be even worse
for them after death.
But there, I think,
the Epicureans are wrong.
There are plenty of reasons
other than the fear of postmortem distress
for preferring fardels
to a bare bodkin.
Some of the reasons are altruistic.
Hamlet, for example,
might have thought of his duties
as the king of Denmark.
Others are egocentric.
Hamlet might have thought of his plan
to discovering exactly
how many things there are
in heaven and earth
which are not dreamt up
in Horatio's philosophy.
(audience laughing)
Those are not reasons,
or not all of my reasons
for fearing death,
but they are reasons for
being concerned about death
or worrying about dying,
for wanting, sometimes wanting very much
not to die now.
No argument connects
to abate such worries,
nor should it,
because they are reasonable worries.
So what's to be done?
This is really the end, okay?
If philanthropic Epicureans
do not, in the end,
provide us satisfactory answers,
the question,
what's to be done,
what can we poor philosophers do?
What can we say to those about to die?
Two things, right?
First of all,
do all you can
to make sure that other people
and other things don't
depend on your own survival.
I have insured my life.
I've set up a trust fund
for my grandchildren.
And I'm determined to
accept no appointment
in the armed forces from now on.
(audience laughing)
Secondly, the older I get,
the more I adjust my plans and projects.
I keep them short-term.
Those projects I have now
can either be carried on successfully
by someone else after I'm dead
or only take another 2
1/2 minutes, I think,
or anyway, are projects I
don't care too much about.
That, I think,
is the philosophical
answer to the question:
What should we do about
the prospect of dying?
You will perhaps think
this is not really a philosophical answer.
Rather, it's an answer
given by common sense.
Well, I agree.
But as Bishop Berkeley put it,
one of the chief tasks of philosophy
is to be eternally a calling man
to common sense.
(audience applauding)
(serene music)